How long do I wait to recheck after my pet scan and what scan do I request?
I doubt my insurance company will pay for it on a pet scan, especially since they probably
only did this one because it was six months I check up after my double mastectomy and I
did quite conventional treatment for the afternoons.
My oncologist still has not called about my results.
No, well if pet scans didn't have any ill effects, no radiation, no markers, no glucose
use, etc, it would be a wonderful world and if they were free, we could just do it every
week and we could see the progress objectively, our treatment for the close.
However, we don't live in a perfect world and none of those things are true.
So how long are you going to wait to do that on a pet scan?
Well, that is dependent upon a couple of things, whether the oncologist would do it, whether
your insurance would pay for it, even if you were a wealthy woman, you could, I'd say I
was going to pay for it on a clock of myself, the oncologist might be stubborn and not even
ordered for you.
So then you have to deal with the ill effects is the pros of going by progress, more important
than the ill's of radiating my body and causing damage to my body, remember, a pet scan is
prevalent, I don't remember, getting like 50 chest checks, right?
So you can't just pull pull that and say that that isn't, I'll be fine, if you get
enough pet scans and CT scans and MRIs, you could have ill effects and that can be cancer
causing in itself.
So you've got to weigh all these things out, what's important for you to know, are there other
objective tests that you can do that can give you enough data for you to be confident that
you're moving in the right direction, I don't know, everybody has to make that decision
for themselves, I for one don't want to get any CTs or anything.